[Music]
look at this poor guy we're not picking
up a hitchhiker he could very easily be
a serial killer and I don't want to be
late to mom's wedding hey fellas we got
a nervous Nellie here so this is gonna
sound like a funny question but are you
a serial killer I am NOT a serial killer
you just emphasize the word serial
you're still not saying I promise I'm
not a killer
we'll give you a ride but those aren't
too tight are they almost kill you can't
kill you I probably should have told you
long ago I made up all those stories
about your father okay way that he died
of colon cancer I'm not sure who your
father was I spent my whole life trying
to honor his memory this means I stare
at [ __ ] for a living because of a
fictional man's colon cancer could you
give it into plastic surgery or
something less but related he's out
there yeah fine dad let's do it
mom actually dated Terry Bradshaw do you
remember a woman named Helen Baxter talk
about a blast from the past
she had the tightest ass you've ever
saved and a set of knockers all damn
near cost us a Super Bowl who's Roland
hunt
you guys are Lennie Baxter's kids so
what are you doing here we think we're
your sons he runs a hot just like you it
sounds like you've had an awful day
was ahead because a person and yet an
amazing day
are you ready for me
why don't you just stop this foolishness
who your father is or isn't is totally
irrelevant we almost got killed
we just had one of the best adventures
of our life Oh guys my negro spider
sense is tingling
that's all train
bastards as the name Helen Baxter ring a
bell it does more than ringing Bell Oh
Ron woman was like a dick whisperer
what makes you think about Helen Baxter
she's our mom all we did was cook the
Mariana she know what is culturally
incest night terror what are we thinking
it's glam bad this boy absolutely not
wait what's that one there I love it I
only trouble is his pants are just a
little